Three, two, one Aloha. Welcome to the Lang focus channel.
And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to focus on the Hawaiian language or all
[inaudible] in Hawaiian. Obviously it's a language of Hawaii. Wait,
let me say that again, Hawaii. Yeah. Notice there's a glottal stop right there.
Have I eat?
Of course it's no longer the main language of Hawaii or even a widely spoken one
only around 18,000 of Hawaii's 1.4 million people speak it at home.
That's according to the U S census of 2010,
and there's only one place in the world where it's the native language and the
main language of the population, the Island of Niihau,
which has a population of only around 160.
But even though it's not widely spoken anymore,
you do see and hear a lot of Hawaiian words in Hawaii.
You'll most definitely hear a low, hot meaning, both hello and goodbye,
but actually literally means love Aloha Mahalo, meaning thank you, Mahalo.
And you'll encounter countless Hawaiian place names like Waikiki,
which means spouting water is water.
Allah means ocean path or path to the sea.
Allah is path or way Milena is sea or ocean
and lots of shops and businesses use Hawaiian words in their names like the
hotel. My wife and I recently stayed at Ohana.
Malia Waikiki Ohana means family Ohana,
and this word Coca-Cola means help. And here we see Mahalo again.
So you can see that in Hawaii,
Hawaiian words are sometimes thrown in when using English,
the first Hawaiian people migrated to the islands from other parts of Polynesia.
We don't know when exactly,
but the common theory is that the first wave of migrations came from the Mar
CASIS islands as early as 400 CE followed by a second wave of migration
from Tahiti several centuries later, as a result of that,
Hawaiian shares many similarities with the Mark Casen and Tahitian languages.
Despite the geographic distance European explorers,
notice the similarities and thought that all the languages were dialects of a
single Polynesian language.
But at least now there are plenty of differences too. When British Explorer,
captain James Cook first reached Hawaii in 1778,
the population was around 300,000 and they all spoke Hawaiian
American missionary soon arrived as well as American businessmen who established
sugarcane plantations along with them came diseases such as smallpox,
which wiped out much of the native population by 1860.
There were only around 60,000 native Hawaiians. And by 1920,
only 24,000 many immigrants also came to Hawaii to work on
plantations. During this period from Asian countries like Japan, China,
and Philippines speaking, their respective languages in 1893,
the kingdom of Hawaii was overthrown with the intention of annexing it to the
United States. In 1896,
a law was passed making English the language of instruction in Hawaiian schools.
Hawaiian was not made illegal to speak, but at school children were disciplined.
If they spoke Hawaiian this along with the largely decimated native population,
put the Hawaiian language at serious risk of dying out over the next century.
It's a language that many predicted would be dead by now, but in recent decades,
there's been more attention to preserving and promoting the language in the
1980s.
New Hawaiian immersion schools began to be established including immersion
preschools in 1979, before the establishment of the schools,
there were only around 800 native speakers of Hawaiian remaining.
But now according to the latest us census,
there were around 18,000 people who speak Hawaiian at home.
That doesn't necessarily mean it's their first language,
but that they are fluent speakers.
And many of them must be among the people who studied at immersion schools.
Now let's take a look at some of the languages. Key features,
pronunciation and orthography.
Hawaiian is written with only eight consonant letters.
One is a glottal stop called Okinawa. We heard it before in Hawaii.
Again,
notice that Hawaii also note that certain letters can represent two
different sounds depending on the dialect or accent,
but spelling is now standardized to these particular letters.
The letter w can represent woop or it's more commonly pronounced
these days, but it depends on the speaker and the dialect,
their speeches influenced by it as well as on the surrounding sounds,
Hawaiian has five vowels,
a E O O plus [inaudible] Elian placed over
a vowel to indicate that it's a long vowel.
There are no consonant clusters in Hawaiian. In other words,
there are never two consonants in a row. Every syllable ends in a vowel,
a Loha Maha lo or Hannah, et cetera.
The stress of a word usually falls on the penultimate syllable.
The second last syllable, here are some basic phrases in Hawaiian.
We've seen the first one already. Aloha. Hello, goodbye or love.
Aloha. Good.
Morning between the hours of about 6:00 AM to 10:00 AM.
Kia. Good.
Day from around 10:00 AM to 2:00 PM.
Aloha good afternoon.
From around 2:00 PM to 6:00 PM.
Aloha good evening from around 6:00 PM to 10:00 PM.
Be here or how are you?
Make a you on good awake quinoa. What's your name?
[inaudible].
My name is Kai.
Noah notice here that Cole your and co my are two completely
different words. So you can't skip the glottal stop in Hawaiian words.
[Inaudible] please Mahalo. Thank you. Hey Mikey.
You're welcome. Literally a little thing.
Let's examine the word order of Hawaiian a little bit. Look at the sentence,
make it doesn't have a verb,
but notice that the predicate comes first and the subject comes second word for
word. It's good. I, this is very common in Austronesian.
Languages ended immediately reminded me of Tagalog a language of the
Philippines.
Okay. Norco. We know.
Word for word it's personal topic. Marker. Kai Noah. My name,
the subject is co UE Noah and the predicate is okay.
You Noah also it's similar. If the predicate is an adjective.
And then Nika Bohemia, the woman is beautiful.
Literally beautiful. The woman. And that's a full sentence.
[inaudible] means the beautiful woman and is not a full sentence.
There's no predicate. It's simply a noun phrase in Hawaiian noun phrases.
If there's an adjective, the adjective comes after the noun. Whereas in English,
it comes before it another example.
New [inaudible] means the house is big, but [inaudible].
It means that the big house, if we had a verb,
we can see that Hawaiian is VSO. Aloha. Yeah. I love you.
Word for word. Love I,
you and you can see that it's V S O verb,
subject object as a side note. Oh,
is the first person singular subject pronoun. Yeah. Oh,
is the second person singular object pronoun.
[Inaudible] I want.
Some water word for word.
Want I direct object marker the water again.
We see that the verb comes first followed by the subject then by the object,
this word E is a direct object marker that is used before common knelt.
So now we have an idea of the most basic word order of Hawaiian articles
and determiners. We've seen many nouns proceeded by cup.
This is a definite article. There's one more K K is used before.
Now it's beginning with K E a or O like kumu the teacher
before now it's starting with any other letter it's caught,
which is more common.
There's also a plural definite article NA NA Kumo, the teachers.
There's also an indefinite article. Hey, Hey, Como a teacher.
You can make the indefinite now in plural by adding a plural marker.
Mo [inaudible].
Teachers. Similarly, there are demonstratives.
Okay. Yeah, it means this [inaudible]. This cat can NA means that.
That for things that are near the listener can not that cat.
Can LA means that for things.
That are far from both the speaker and the listener.
Kayla.
To make the demonstrative plural, you can add Mo key, your mobile bookie.
These cats. Now let's look at possessives.
Or co Evo. Kayla, that's.
My dog over there. Word for word it's equative sentence. Marker.
My dog that in the distance, just a quick note about, Oh,
this word comes at the beginning of equative sentences,
which are used to specifically identify something.
But back to the main point here, this word here is a possessive meaning.
My possessives in Hawaiian are interesting because there's more than one version
of each one is an A-class possessive.
A-class possessives are used for things you can choose whether to possess or
not. If you have a dog,
you probably chose to buy it and can choose to get rid of it.
Of course you probably won't because dogs are man's best friend, but you know,
you could,
the OIC last equivalent is co w O class possessives are mainly used with
nouns that you cannot choose to possess. You inherently possess them.
Or [inaudible].
This is my sister. You can't decide whether you have a sister or not.
So this is old class.
There is an exception for this for family members below you in your family tree,
like children and grandchildren,
a classes used A-class can be used for things that you create.
And I guess you create your children, making them A-class
things like body parts are also okay.
[Inaudible] I mean, it's my eye, Colima.
My arm or my hand, et cetera.
One caveat is that clothing and structures that you can enter or ride are also
old class as though they are extensions of your body.
Or [inaudible]. That.
Is our house over there.
Notes that with Hawaiian possessives and Hawaiian personal pronouns,
there is first person plural inclusive. In other words, we,
or our includes the listener and first person plural exclusive.
In other words, we, or our doesn't include the listener.
This is common in Austronesian languages. I've seen something similar in Malay,
Indonesian and toget log. This possessive here, Cole,
Marco excludes the listener. One more thing,
which is special about Hawaiian possessives and personal pronouns is that there
is not just one set of plural forms. There are dual forms,
which refer to pairs of people. And there are plural forms,
which refer to groups of three or more.
New Ecolab, their.
Houses big, this refers to three or more people's house.
But if I said lower [inaudible], it would refer to two people's
house. Now let's look a little more closely at verbs you saw before that there
is
no verb, meaning to be another important thing to point out is that verbs are not conjugated
for person or number. They stayed the same regardless of the subject.
He Minio. I sing he mini oil. You sing, he mini oil.
He sings, or she sings. He mini LACOE.
And so on
tense aspect and mood markers are used before or after the verb to indicate the
relationship of action to time. For example,
K plus verb plus ne equals the present continuous.
[Inaudible]. I am.
Working watch. Plus verb equals the perfective aspect,
showing that an action is complete. Often.
This translates as the past tense [inaudible] I or I have worked
a plus verb plus Ana equals the imperfection of aspect,
which indicates that an action has not been completed.
This often translates as the future tense in English,
but can also be used for an incomplete action. In the past,
I will work or I was working a plus the verb equals the
imperative form. It work.
It can also function as the infinitive to work for the negative imperative you
use my [inaudible] don't work.
Now let's look at a final sentence in Hawaiian and break it down.
[Inaudible].
I went shopping with my friends on Sunday word for word it's perfective marker,
go.
I infinitive shop with my plural marker friend
on the Sunday. First we see the perfective aspect marker,
which shows that this action is complete. Again,
notice that the sentence is verb initial. The subject comes after the verb.
Next we see the infinitive form of the verb,
meaning to buy or shop next may is a preposition meaning with
there are a few prepositions in Hawaiian E meaning two on it or
at ma meaning on it or at,
but not to may meaning with O and ah,
meaning of there are two forms here because there's a distinction between Oh,
class and A-class and no,
and not meaning belonging to again, the first one is, Oh, class.
And the second one is a class. Next we see the possessive coat. Ooh,
meaning my or mine, which is, Oh, class friends are treated as Oh class,
whereas A-class would indicate a romantic relationship.
Mo is the plural marker making Hawaii Aloha plural.
And here's another one of those prepositions in this case,
meaning on and Gullah Pula means Sunday being the definite
article. Hawaiian is a fun language,
a logical language and an accessible language.
It's not difficult to learn a little bit and get started speaking fairly
quickly, especially thanks to its simple phonology.
Unfortunately there aren't that many people to speak with,
but with the increasing number of second language speakers, since the 1980s,
hopefully Hawaiian will continue to regain some of its former glory.
Duolingo actually has a Hawaiian course now,
and it's an easy way to experience a little of this fun language to see if you
like it. The question of the day for speakers of Hawaiian,
if there are any of you watching,
how much do you speak Hawaiian on a day-to-day basis and in what situations and
for other people, what's your impression of Hawaiian after seeing this video,
leave your comments down below.
Be sure to check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms.
And as always, I want to say a special thanks to my Patrion supporters.
These people right here on the screen are my top tier of Patrion supporters.
So many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.